hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
hearts of Westminster where there were
three and a half hours of questions for
Boris Johnson from MPS on the Privileges
committee today all to find out did the
former prime minister knowingly mislead
the house over lockdown parties in
Downing Street he was emphatic verging
on Angry in his denials to what some of
his supporters call a kangaroo court but
there were difficult questions and some
awkward exchanges we'll have to wait for
a verdict that could just could lead to
his removal from Parliament well on an
extremely busy political day where she
sunak overwhelmingly won a key vote on
his new deal with the EU in Northern
Ireland oh when he finally published his
tax returns a good day to do that
perhaps plenty to get stuck into as we
bring you takes from all sides over the
next 60 minutes
I swear by almighty God that the
evidence I shall give for this committee
should be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help me God
Boris Johnson said he truly believed
what he was saying was correct and he
followed the rules to the best of his
ability
people who say that we were partying in
lockdown simply do not know what they
are talking about
plenty of his answers left some on the
committee less than impressed and there
would now be a very nervous wait for its
reports meanwhile
the eyes to the right
515 the nose to the left 29.
22 of his own party voted against the
key storm and break that's part of the
PM's deal with the EU in Northern
Ireland but it sailed through the
commons with labor support and then we
had this the prime minister's tax
Affairs for the last three years were
published and it told us what we already
knew he is a very rich man and he's paid
hundreds of thousands of pounds of tax
on millions of pounds of capital gains
so we've got some great guests on the
show today including the chair of the
conservative party Greg hands and what
must be a very busy day for him
for labor will be joined by the party
Shadows Secretary of State for
environment food and Rural Affairs
that's Jim McMahon
and we're going to be talking to Jim
Shannon for the dep and much more just
but decides all coming up on the take
[Music]
[Applause]
hello well it's been quite the day here
in Westminster a former prime minister
grilled by MPS for hours a current PM
publishing is long-awaited tax return a
vote on The Windsor framework that would
dominate the news on any normal day and
we haven't even mentioned PM Keys so
let's crack straight on shall we can
start with the popcorn moment earlier
and Boris Johnson was up in front of the
Privileges committee
I'm here to say to you hand on heart
that I did not lie to the house but it
never occurred to me or I think the
current prime minister at the time that
the event was not in compliance with the
rules that the press conferences over
this period you regularly repeated the
phrase hands face space so there can be
no doubt that you understood what the
guidance and the rules meant and were
intended to to achieve yes or no yes
thank you
the question is uh whether what you said
about this particular way of thanking
your staff in the House of Commons was
strictly accurate the guidance does not
say uh you can have a thank you party I
I believed that this event was uh not
only reasonably necessary but it was
essential for work purposes but another
witness State stated that they couldn't
get through the room to leave because
people were standing four to five people
deep is there any reason why we should
disbelieve that people who say that we
were partying in lockdown simply do not
know what they are talking about so why
did you tell the household guidance was
followed completely in number 10. nobody
came to me and said uh we've got a
problem with this one did any government
law officer or any member of the
government legal department did anyone
of those give you the Assurance the
short answer is no they didn't we would
be entitled to be a bit dismayed about
the flimsy nature of this assurance when
we took it at value that these
assurances amounted to something and it
looks from what you've told us in answer
to Mr coss's questions that they did not
amount to much at all
extraordinary to witness that today now
a little earlier as Boris Johnson was
giving the evidence that we just saw I
spoke to the chair of the conservative
party Greg hands
so we're doing this interview at 4 30.
at 2PM today Boris Johnson started his
evidence to the Privileges committee
about whether he misled Parliament at 2
30 MPS vote on wish you see your next
brexit deal and we're imminently
expecting to see the Prime Minister
publish his tax returns now you had
control over the timing of two out of
three of these things so why are they
all happening on the same day well it's
it's a busy day in politics so if it's
been a lot of busy days in politics the
last few years obviously the Privileges
committee is working to the timetable of
the Privileges committee uh Rishi suno
has got a commitment to publish his tax
returns as is Kia starma I might add as
well I think it's pure coincidence
they're happening on the same day pure
coincidence come on you're taking some
fools there you know Richard Cena
promised to publish his Tax Returns on
the 16th of November he's just
coincidentally happened to do it on the
day that Boris Johnson's appearing in
front of the Privileges committee we're
supposed to believe that well I think
the you're right the prime minister has
pledged to publish his tax returns kirst
armor has also pledged to publish his
taxes I'll talk about the timing
the the timing I believe is a
coincidence I don't think there's
anything else out there I think in terms
of the Privileges committee that's down
to the Privileges Committee in terms of
the legislation we would always be clear
have been clear that we would publish
the uh the Windsor framework as
negotiated back at Windsor with us sort
of underlying about three or four weeks
ago and it would be published in due
course that is the good timing to do
this people have had plenty of time to
study the document both within the
conservative party dup and elsewhere and
it's not unusual that vote should be
held today on a Wednesday there's a
reason I'm starting with the timing
because I do think this is quite
important it makes it harder for people
like me to do our jobs properly to
scrutinize things properly when you're
trying to cram say much not just in a
day in a matter of four hours
well I I think it has Commons has coped
well the turnout has been high in those
votes uh it's the same day as prime
minister's question time I don't think
it has put a burden on the House of
Commons and a burden on people here uh
being able to do that scrutiny the uh
Windsor framework has been published
some time ago allowing people to look at
that and Boris Johnson's appearance at
the Privileges committee is obviously
something which is if you like a part of
that process which is down to Parliament
we haven't seen the tax return yet from
which you see neck we were awaiting it
it was expected to come at 4 P.M what we
know is it will show that the prime
minister is extremely wealthy does that
mean that he's out of touch no I don't
think so at all actually uh I don't
think so it means that actually Rishi
comes from a relatively modest
background his parents ran a pharmacy in
Southampton you know he's somebody who
yes he is wealthy now but does not come
from that sort of a background it comes
from a background of immigration into
this country three parents who ran a
pharmacy one of his parents of the GP
you know it's a it's a not a poor
background but not an unusual background
do you think most people who come from
relatively modest backgrounds go to
Winchester school then but I think
actually as parents saved up a lot of
money and works really hard to get their
child into a very very good school I
think is actually something to admire in
his parents when people look at the tax
return some people may think look this
is a guy who has a lot of of wealth how
can he understand the issues of the
country's mail going through how can you
understand what parents are going
through for example who's send their
kids to the local state school and they
feel that they don't have enough money
to properly give their kid the education
that they deserve or he doesn't
understand the energy bill crisis that
so many people are struggling with well
I disagree with that look I don't think
there's a correlation between someone's
personal wealth and where they are in
terms of understanding the public the
most important thing is that Rishi sunic
has shown by his delivery so far this
year and his priorities that he has got
the Public's priorities by halving
inflation growing the economy reducing
debt reducing Hospital waiting lists and
also stopping the boats are the people's
priorities and that's what he should be
judged on the delivery of those
priorities and Delivery for the people
of the United Kingdom okay well we'll
find out more of course when the tax
returns are published and but just to
talk about if I may the Windsor
framework the brexit deal for Northern
Ireland passed relatively easy there
were rebellions from the conservative
side it was a three-line whip I think so
will there be repercussions of people
who rebelled well that'd be a matter um
for the whips office rather than a
matter for me as chairman of the
conservative party
um the most important thing here is that
we got the deal through
um and with a resounding a really solid
vote amongst a conservative MPS the vast
majority of conservative MP supported it
and it's something that people said
wasn't possible that it wasn't possible
to get a good deal with Brussels that
works for the people of Northern Ireland
that works for the people of the whole
of the United Kingdom unionist voters in
Northern Ireland three to one in favor
of doing this deal and Rishi sunak has
shown that he can deliver on the
people's priorities which includes
coming to a good deal which keeps
Northern Ireland's place in the United
Kingdom respects the openness of the
Irish Border and actually leads to an
improving working relationship with
Brussels as well it's all about Northern
Ireland of course they're still and yet
the eight Union smps dup MPS didn't vote
for it does that matter well it's
ultimately important that the deal went
through as I said I think the people of
Northern Ireland overall strongly
support the deal unionist voters support
the deal at a ratio of three to one
what's your sort of evidence for that
I think it was an opinion poll overnight
uh which the secretary for Northern
Ireland uh referenced today and I think
it's been referenced elsewhere okay okay
a couple
of course rebound on it including two
former Prime Ministers Liz truss and
also Boris Johnson were disappointed to
see them not following you through the
same voting Lobby well I'm always
disappointed when people aren't
supporting the government
um but nonetheless I think it was a real
achievement to get that through vast
majority why do you think Liz truss and
Boris Johnson didn't back it do you
think it's because they didn't think it
was a good deal or because they actually
just don't really like Richardson I I
think it's a question better put to them
what I'm clear about is two things that
is a good deal a good deal for the
people of the UK a good deal for people
in Northern Ireland and a good deal for
conservative MPS as well who also
looking to move on uh past brexit and to
look forward to a more normal
relationship a more normal relationship
also in terms of our trade across the
Irish sea make sure that trade flows
better
committee
well look it's a it's Parliament has
voted uh to give the Privileges
committee that investigation uh it that
is a matter for Parliament the
parliament that's not my that's not my
question do you have confidence in the
Privileges committee well again I do
think that as a matter of a parliament
if you're asking for me personally or
the conservative party we don't take a
position on that that is a matter for
Parliament it's a matter for MPS who've
asked the Privileges committee to set up
this inquiry okay
you're an MP do you have confidence in
the Privileges committee it's not a
trick question it's it's quite simple
question right well but the way I've
been an MP for 18 years nobody ever
asked do you have confidence in this
committee or that committee the
Committees get appointed by parliament
in case some cases I think elected by
Parliament and is properly a matter for
Parliament it's not a matter of my
individual opinion as an MP I have
confidence in Parliament structures
overall okay so if the Privileges
committee find that MP misled Parliament
deliberately and as a result was in
contempt of the house should they be
able to continue as nmp or do you think
they should be suspended well I think
that again is we'll have to see what the
Privileges committee does in this case
uh we have been clear the Prime Minister
has been clear it'll be a free vote for
conservative MPS we'll have to see what
the Privileges committee recommends that
that is the purpose of their
investigation will you follow the
recommendations of the Privileges
committee well I think it'll be free
vote for MPS we'll have to see what the
the investigation throws up and what the
recommendation is I wouldn't want to
prejudge anything until then okay
restaurants in a liar
look I think that is one of the
questions that I think the Privileges
committee is looking at you know whether
he I think he's now said that he feels
he did mislead Parliament so the
question is whether he willfully uh
misled Parliament that is if you like
the question in front of the Privileges
committee I'll wait and see that
investigation do you have an opinion on
it though do you think he did willfully
mislead or lie as other people might fit
it I think the purpose the Privileges
committee is to look at all that
evidence I would want to see you if I
were
following it closely which I am I would
like to see what evidence he's given to
the Privileges committee uh what
evidence have other people given what of
a senior civil servant said what if
special advisors said I'd want to see
all of the evidence I mean you say
you've been following it closely so what
do you think so far
in terms of his own uh evidence I'd like
to see other evidence as well and I'm
sure everybody will want to see other
evidence and look closely at what's been
said so you haven't made up your mind
then I mean that feels quite significant
in a way I mean here's the guy who you
know was prime minister for the concept
but I think that's the purpose of the
investigation is to get to the bottom
the the committee hearings or to get to
the bottom of who said what when
I mean his defense seems to be that you
know if you worked in a stressful
environment like number 10 during
lockdown then the rules and regulations
and guidelines didn't apply in the same
way and did you get that memory I don't
look uh I I think it's a question better
put to him obviously Boris is leading
his own defense
uh he ample opportunity today to lay
that out I wouldn't really want to sort
of paraphrase what his defense is I
think the most important thing is to
wait for the committee to report have a
look at their report so you're party
chairman you're the man in charge of
making sure the conservatives don't get
annihilated at the next election if you
look at the polls that's not a complete
impossibility is Boris Johnson an asset
to the conservative party well I think
Boris Johnson is a great campaigning
asset to the conservative party uh only
now I'm actually asking Boris if it will
come out and campaign with us for
example one of my local issue campaigns
in London is saving some of our bus
routes Boris is passionate about London
buses he brought in the root master bus
when he was the the fresh root master
password who's mayor of London I think
he's a campaigning asset for the
conservative party you still think that
he's a campaigning asset to the
conservative party even though you know
people who that went through an awful
lot in lockdown people who couldn't see
their loved ones in Care Homes people
who couldn't Comfort their loved ones at
funerals they'll be looking at a man who
admits to misleading Parliament over his
own actions and those of those in number
10. a man who was fined by police were
breaking lockdown rules and you still
think he's an asset a campaigning asset
again I wouldn't want to pre-charge the
standards committee investigation I've
told you things that we are not already
know that he's won by police and that he
is that uh look I I I work with Boris
over a long time he's been mayor of
London I'm a London mp uh worked to them
on the 2008 campaign 2012 campaign his
time as prime minister what I'm clear
about is that Boris Johnson is a
campaigning asset for the conservative
party and that is why we should be using
Boris as somebody who will be
campaigning uh in parts of the country
for us at the next general election to
return a conservative government under
Russia is he a man of integrity look I
think Boris is is a man who's a
reasonably well known uh what his
strengths are what his weaknesses are
his great strength I think in this case
is his ability to campaign his ability
to Galvanize voters as part of a broader
conservative family I'm somebody who
served under different Prime Ministers
under David Cameron under Boris Johnson
and the Rishi sunak now and I'm
confident that Boris Johnson can be a
campaigning asset for the conservatives
and the lead-up to next year's general
election but you're not saying that he's
a man of integrity well look that's I'm
not I'm I'm in the business of politics
not moral judgment calls and when it
comes to politics I know that Boris
Johnson is somebody who can campaign
well for us and I'm looking forward to
seeing him campaigning for us at the
general election and for him to be
re-elected as the MP for Oxbridge and
South ruislip
now at shall we which one as usual on
the take from uh by our Deputy political
editor Sam Coates
it was interesting talking to Greg hanza
he wanted to be loyal towards Bruce
Johnson he was saying he was a great
campaigning asset he wants to get him
out on the campaign Trail when I asked
him the question about this is Rishi
United's tax Affairs by the way it's not
totally sure
later absolutely smooth ship as always
um but when I asked him the question
direct question is Boris Johnson a man
of integrity he couldn't answer it could
he
no and I think that a lot of Tory MPS
have been looking at the three and a
half hour circus today
um partly wondering what it's all gonna
end up being but probably in large part
thinking my God thank goodness he's not
prime minister anymore because this
process would have happened had Boris
Johnson been in number 10 or not and and
I think that
underneath it there are a couple of
games going on there is the uh decision
for the committee to make about whether
or not they're going to recommend so I'm
going to sanction against Boris Johnson
if they determined that he uh knowingly
misled Parliament and the courtesy were
quite methodological in the way that
they proceeded today I mean it was
fairly clear they made up their mind
right the way that they addressed uh
this man here all the way through made
it look as if they're they are likely to
to find he has been guilty of breaking
some of the of the commons rules but
there's a bigger thing going on which is
people are sort of reassessing and
engaging with what Boris Johnson
returning to our lives is like and what
was really striking about the hearing is
that time and again you were struck by
when something goes wrong for Boris
Johnson he's the opposite of curious
he's the most uh the sort of most
incurious person he relies on the
smallest of reassurances from one Aid or
another over some of the biggest
problems that come down the track he's
not an individual you get the sense that
goes looking for an issue that then he
feels the need to solve when he's asked
about partygate by The Daily Mirror uh
the strategy is how to minimize the
damage not how to get to the bottom of
what might have gone on there is an
element that Boris Johnson that's kind
of hear no evil see no evil uh and and
sort of defend defend defend and the
other really interesting thing and I was
actually driving in listening to the
hearings in my car so not normally it's
a slightly less engaged than I normally
would be and the thing that I just came
on with this impression that you know
for the two years the 18 months of the
pandemic
I thought there was a man standing
behind a Podium every day telling us
that the rules were incredibly strict
but today I listened to the same man sit
in front of that committee and the rules
had kind of holds in all over the place
everything had an exception everything
had a reason why you didn't have to
follow the social distancing it's very
clear that the guidance didn't mean that
you had to obey every piece of social
distinct advice there were exceptions
everywhere I mean crikey you sort of
came away thinking what lockdown
listening to his version of what what
you had to follow yeah I I felt myself
doing a kind of re-examination as well
because I I will always remember what it
was like to do this job during covert
right to interview government ministers
and to try and be is on top of the rules
as possible so that we could tell our
viewers what was going on and Harrogate
our politicians I don't remember Matt
Hancock saying it was illegal to sunbait
in the park on your own and I I honestly
I kind of feel again going kind of
through the Looking Glass on this have I
got this completely wrong the whole time
about the rules and the guidance like it
makes you come and question it yeah
Boris Johnson was reeling off the fact
that things would say to the best of
your ability when it comes to workplace
social distancing he was unpicking what
uh one meter plus meant and what the
exceptions were he was um stressing
where necessary the voluntary nature of
what was going on he was making clear uh
that celebrations of Staff although he
wouldn't call it a party was absolutely
within the rules because that was part
of motivating the people that you work
alongside I mean they just were not
conversations that you or I and almost
all of the country had in 2020 and 2021
so it's slightly odd hearing it like
that today thanks very much Sam we'll
have more from Sam later on the program
are you watching the take we're live in
Westminster as usual for you up next
we're going to be focusing on the boats
over the Windsor framework talking to
one of the dep MPS that voted against
the deal
[Music]
I was interested in Afghanistan and lost
my boat legs and
sustained some multiple injuries you
were very overwhelmed and depressed at
the time weren't you yes yeah one point
it was I thought that my life was
completely finished it was actually a
really hard work initially I started
um Sports and an adventure and started
getting my confidence slowly and slowly
and golf was one of them and did other
bits and yeah I think that I can climb
to Mount Everest so so these are my
walking legs so these are the legs that
I use there's a heating system installed
to protect me from frostbite I can't
afford to lose more limbs that's one
thing so I just use a different fix to
climb so these are too heavy one is more
than five kilograms right so I use
smaller legs to carry these are for oh
you've got crampons yeah yeah just for
uh you know ice and snow these were not
designed you can't buy them commercially
and we actually designed these ones they
can go to uh
so it's on your actual web page itself
isn't it yes they can visit
haribbolemaga.com yeah as well and they
can follow me on social media Harry
Potter whole Expedition is for two
months yeah and hopefully just from best
camera up and down we'll take about
seven about seven eight days
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
they welcome live to Westminster you're
watching the take now it's been a packed
day of course those hours of Boris
Johnson facing questions from the
Privileges committee plus votes in
Parliament on the Windsor framework and
Rishi sunak releasing his partial tax
return should I say
MPS are debating The Windsor framework
the amendment to the brexit deal labor
have confirmed they will be going with
the government but no prime minister
wants to be in a position obviously
where he's relying on opposition votes
he's got a choice he can be remembered
for the great acts of statecraft that he
achieved or he can risk looking like a
pound shop Nigel farage to the right
515 the Nosa left 29. prime minister
Rashi sunak published his long-awaited
tax returns they cover his time as both
Chancellor and prime minister over the
last four years you take away really
from it what a wealthy man the prime
minister is so in total shows that he
earned nearly 5 million pounds from a
combination of his salary his
Investments the only equivalent
investigation he's ever been involved in
is the one that found him guilty of
breaking the law I said at the time I
respected the decision the police
reached and I offered an unreserved
apology
well today 29 MPS voted against the key
part of British cnx New brexit Deal
including all of the democratic unionist
parties MPS where we're joined now by
the dep MP Jim Shannon to talk about why
your party decided ultimately you
couldn't support
okay well thank you first of all this
will be foreign a pleasure to be here to
give our point of view and hopefully
it'll be with your viewers was to hear
um simply hit me it didn't mark up to
our expectations number one we sought
legal opinion on the matter we had hoped
to have uh the final legal opinion by
the end of this week we felt that
government perhaps had rushed it a wee
bit there in relation bringing this
forward uh there's a choreographer there
following sethovich and James clevery's
meeting on Friday but legally the
opinions we got back were quite clear
that it wasn't as a platitude of words
it certainly wasn't any way legally
binding and we felt that particularly uh
disappointed by by government's decision
to go forward today do you think that
you were misled them about the strength
of it that we talked about the storm
will break what I thought I always try
to be careful with my words I think the
the Prime Minister was certainly over
enthusiastic when we when he was in the
Coca-Cola factory we wondered how he
don't call the cook because he was
obviously bouncing from foot to foot he
was in a high uh that right away put us
on a regard because we fully
refrigerated herself I mean that can't
be that's good well that certainly
wasn't that wasn't even good at all so
it's rather disappointing that we find
ourselves in this uh position where we
have a very very large Divergence of
opinion between the conservative party
and ourselves in relation to legally the
storm would break is nothing more than a
handbrake it's not a stop it's a hand
break it's a story handbrake is better
than nothing though isn't it and also
it's something that many people have
said you won't be able to do at all
well I have to say sorry if I thought
that the handbrake would stay on uh and
then I would say to myself that's that
we have something to work on uh today uh
um the uh Secretary of State Crescent
Harris give us his opinion his opinion
was uh that uh that 30 mlas from two
different parties two different groups
can uh can ask for any a new EU
legislation to be stopped now with that
when you look at that initially you say
well that's good but then we found out
it's it's conditional first of all it
goes I'm not quite sure what it means
about this going to a community then it
comes to Westminister so what we need to
have is a legally binding document
written and written and and the laws of
Westminster that we have in the screen
behind us in a way that we know then we
have we can depend upon the 30 mlas to
actually do something but here's a
here's the problem the problem is it
goes to Westminster it goes to the
government whoever the minister is in
charge and prime minister their name
again decision whether or not to to
support and and back the 30 mlas the
legal opinion that we get tells us that
it's nothing more than words so I'm
sorry uh to say that that we're not
convinced and by the way there's better
legal Minds than me and just Jim Sean
I'm not a legal mind but but people are
I never advisors the ARG had their legal
opinion separate opinion uh they were in
order back home and and some of the
loyalist groups had their illegal
opinion a different legal opinion but
all those legal opinions came to the
same conclusion it's not legally binding
it doesn't work what would you say to
people who might be listening to you and
thinking look
the cat's out of the bag the dep are
never going to back anything when it
comes to a brexit deal in the EU you're
always going to hold out you're always
going to find a problem and you're never
going to accept it uh I I would say that
we've been trying to find a problem uh
look we we're we believe in Devolution
we want to see Devolution being
successful uh we would love to have a um
uh um an agreement before us at at
Westminster that that gives us an Avenue
and a Way Forward uh from the very
beginning we have had discussions with
uh the prime minister with James
cleverley with the uh the Secretary of
State and other members of the of the uh
conservative party to try and find a
constructive way forward we have
intermitted to the conservative party
that there are a number of outstanding
issues which have not been addressed now
there are things some of the green knee
and stuff is positive but the negatives
are that that the veterinary medicines
hasn't sorted the issue of of calc
movements to to Sterling and and to to
Barrack are not sorted the issue of
fishing uh um issues not one of them has
been sorted the Constitutional position
has not been sorted uh the EO the the
European court has has not been sorted
so we we've asked for things to be done
the unfortunate thing is we've asked for
weeks and they haven't seemed to have
tried at all the other thing that hasn't
been sorted is the government in
Northern Ireland it's still not still
not up and running what is the dep's
position are you now prepared to
re-enter government uh I I think that
today's voters uh uh as clearly put our
position on record uh um we we do not
see at this time that we can engage in
in the unassembly once again that we've
asked what's going to happen is it's
just gonna I mean this is a huge issue
for people in Northern Ireland they
haven't got a functioning government a
cost of living crisis what are you going
to re-enter well I mean we we fought an
election uh last year we received a
mandate uh on the Monday it was clear
that the protocol issue had to be sorted
uh the winter framework was put forward
in in an Uber the energetic fashion by
the Prime Minister making it to level
second perhaps it had been sort of the
fact this is not so from our point of
view uh we will continue to engage uh
with I think some of the conservative
MPS today even I think the Secretary of
State to be fair uh had then debated
that the discussions will will be
ongoing so our point of view are still
to be heard now some people would say
look this is just excuses you don't want
to get into government you don't want to
see a champagne press minister no I'm
afraid that does not test you certainly
uh as far as we're concerned as a party
we accept the Democratic mandate we
accepted the Shen Fein are they are the
largest party in the first Minister we
we can't that's the Democratic I'm a
Democrat I believe in that I believe
that wholeheartedly so that's not the
issue the issue is you and I say not you
personally but the government must sort
the issues that we have paid forward to
them they must give us some guarantee on
the Constitutional position of not we've
asked for that I asked for that to and
I'll tell you who the MPS and who the
ministers were who asked me what do we
need I says we need something on the
Constitutional position of Northern
Ireland we're undermined we're weak uh I
want to be as British as what you are
therefore you have to do that so I I
understand lose requests to the
ministers and prominent ministers as
well uh will be um brought to the
attention of the prime minister at their
next meeting of of the uh government so
we we do live in the hope uh but until
that time comes okay I don't believe we
can we can move forward and construct
the fashion I'm sorry to say now while
I've got you and I just want to have a
bit of a change of time because we're
talking an awful lot about uh brexit
we're talking about covid talking about
tax returns and I just want to talk
about this motion here which I have to
you've you've tabled a parliamentary
emotion right and this is to recognize
the 50th anniversary of Dolly Parton's I
will always love you there she is and I
have to admit I am I I I'm a fan and I
love the fact that I heard kids book
scheme which you can access in the UK
it's extraordinary if you haven't heard
of it it's every month any child under
five can get a free book thanks to this
lady it's extremely yeah tonight in
Parliament my uh my labor colleague and
Brian Ruth Cadbury mentioned to me about
that very bookstore thing yeah so it's
kind of I don't know about it by the way
uh but but Dolly Parton uh won a voice
uh what a character uh she's an Ulster
Scott by the way so I think I think her
ancestry probably comes from the same
direction
um but I think as a person that I just
whatever song she sings It's brilliant
uh and and for me and for my wife as
well uh we um we love her uh we love her
music uh and um I think when she sings
wow I just stopped to listen you know I
I think in the Hustler bustle of life as
well and I think it don't make me sound
I think the early day motion today
resonated with so many MPS check it
tomorrow morning you'll see many MPS
have signed it I've had so many Lilly
and Pages said Jamal I just love that
EDM I I signed it right away you know so
tomorrow morning there'll be lots and
lots of MPS who will have signed it
because they love Dolly Parton as well
some of them some of them had their
hands in there they says Jim love Dolly
Parton Isis not as much as me
I love that thank you very much for
being on the program today
oh a different topics covered on the
take we're live in Westminster for you
we're going to be taking a closer look
at Boris Johnson's appearance at the
Privileges committee and get the view
from labor next
up
[Music]
s
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello welcome back we are at the take
you're alive in Westminster we have some
breaking news to bring you now because
we've heard from the prime minister in
the last few minutes this is what he had
to say
being the incredible life-saving work
they do and tomorrow I'll be
highlighting the significant millions of
pounds of UK government investment going
into Wales to help create jobs and
opportunity
well I've got to ask you a couple of
questions prime minister first of all
you have published your tax return today
you're a very wealthy man last year
alone you accrued 1.6 million pounds in
capital gains do you understand what
it's like to be someone striking for
higher pay to be someone struggling to
pay their landlord or heat their home
well I publish my tax returns because I
said I would in the interest of
transparency and I'm glad to have done
that now I think what ultimately what
people are interested in is what I'm
going to do for them and you know you
talk about the cost of living of course
that's the number one priority that I've
got that I'm grappling with that's why
last year we took a decision to tax the
windfall profits of energy companies
we'll tax them at 75 and we're using
that money to help pay People's Energy
bills so over the course of this winter
and Beyond we're going to be paying
about 1 500 pounds of most people's
energy bills that's the type of support
we're providing to help people and that
should give people a sense that I am on
their side I'm doing everything I can to
help them now of course another big
issue today you've passed the first bit
of the Windsor framework through
Parliament but the European research
groups say that you had to rely on labor
party votes in order to do so do you
feel comfortable when your two former
predecessors as prime minister have been
voting against you today but I actually
I think what you said isn't true there
was incredibly strong support for the
Windsor framework not just from my own
party but across Parliament it passed
very solidly with conservative votes and
that's because it is a good deal it is a
good deal for the people for families
for businesses in Northern Ireland the
winter framework restores the balance of
the Belfast Good Friday agreement it
secures Northern Ireland's place in our
Union it restores sovereignty and for
all those Reasons I'm pleased that it
commanded such strong support we're
going to implement it now and make sure
that we can look forward to a brighter
and better future for Northern Ireland
now just finally of course today was
also a big day in Parliament because
your predecessor but one was answering
questions before the Privileges
committee one thing he said was that you
didn't understand why you got a fixed
penalty notice for attending a
rule-breaching event is that true well I
can't obviously comment an ongoing
parliamentary process I'll let that play
out and with regard to myself I
addressed that at the time apologize
unreservedly for what happened
thank you very much
they're answering questions on
everything from his tax return to that
vote on The Windsor framework and of
course on the grilling of Boris Johnson
although he appeared a little bit less
more reluctant shall I say to talk about
that in great depth we can take a closer
look now at the grilling that Boris
Johnson did face from MPS because Jay
Pike has been running his eye over
proceedings
while this inquiry is clearly a make or
break moment for Boris Johnson's
political career so no surprise the
committee room was pretty packed
including with Boris Johnson's laws you
can see him surrounded by a legal team
and when the going got tough they seemed
to intervene a little bit we could see
notes being passed from lawyer to lawyer
and to the lawyer sitting next to Boris
Johnson as well as him taking some
advice and conversations here with Lord
Panic to the left here behind the former
prime minister now we are used to a
jokey pretty bullish a Boris Johnson but
that politician was nowhere to be seen
today he was on pretty serious form
because this is a serious situation
hand on heart that I did not lie to the
house when those statements were made
they were made in good faith
now the committee have loads Reams pages
of written evidence but of course this
was a live TV event a visual event so
they rely pretty heavily on photographs
including this one a leaving party in
Downing Street you can see at the front
to the right bottles of alcohol one of
the questioners the smps Alan dorans a
former detective Constable focused on
that issue of why there was alcohol at
this event
would you say that that is strictly
necessary for a work event
it's it's customary to a safer world to
people in this country with a a toast I
didn't see any sign of drunkenness or or
excess well the former prime minister's
defense seemed to be that the rules and
guidance were to an extent up for
interpretation and he said the context
of covert of the pandemic was also
significant it really though got tense
and testy when members of the committee
asked Mr Johnson about his claims to
Parliament that he had received repeated
reassurances that rules and guidance
were adhered to
some might see your Reliance on the
purported assurances you received
as and forgive me as a deflection
mechanism I've tried to describe what I
felt about these events as they were
happening nobody raised with me or had
any concern before I stood up on on
December the 1st
so who do you believe the committee
claimed they have not made their minds
up yet but I'd suggest the tone of
skepticism we heard from some members of
that committee suggest they're not
entirely convinced by Boris Johnson's
Case by his defense we'll find out their
judgment in the coming months
there's RJ Pike talking you through that
explosive a committee session well it's
been a whirlwind day here in Westminster
so let's get Labor's take now because we
are now joined by Jim McMahon who is the
party Shadow environment food and Rural
Affairs secretary thanks for being with
us well let's start with Boris Johnson
uh shall we what do you make of the
evidence
having anybody seeing the uh the
performance that it was a performance uh
in Parliament today I think we'll be
left feeling quite frustrated because
for me this can't be viewed for how we
feel today how we live our lives today
we're free today we can see our friends
and family today we can socialize today
if we have loved ones and Care Homes we
can see them today that wasn't what was
happening when Boris Johnson was
breaking the rules and holding their
Partners in Downing Street and I think
his lack of Emperor and understanding
about what people really went through
for those sacrifices I think for me is
the biggest mistake he has made in that
representation
was there a blurring of the lines though
for people who were allowed within the
rules to work together who were working
in stressful environments who might have
had a glass of wine or a beer at the end
of a day's work when we saw of course
which I know a lot of people about
social media are flagging up kirstalma
with a beer in Durham as well and that's
what the rules allowed for the rules
were that's what he was saying though as
well Boris Johnson says the guidance was
followed well not particularly because
this was about what you could do that
avoided unnecessary contact we were all
asked to keep a two meters or it's not
at least a meter we're all asked to
undergo changes to our daily routines
the difference here and people do make
the equivalent in the way that you've
said uh first of all that kirst armor
didn't break the rules he's pretty clear
that he's a rule maker not a rule
breaker and that was found during the
the inquiry of Honduran police but they
were away staying away for work purposes
Boris Johnson and the staff who worked
in Downing Street were there as their
office and they were having parties
birthday parties Kate was brought in
they literally went to Tesco was so
well of our suitcases bringing in
bottles of wine that wasn't what was
happening in Care Homes it wasn't
happening in hospital Awards and that's
what we've got to compare it to and it
was Boris Johnson you know in the
evening at the podium saying to people
listen this is really important we need
to stay at home we need to save lives
and we need to protect the NHS and
people did that they made the sacrifices
I know what my family went through in
terms of making sacrifices not seeing
each other I've heard your family go
through them we've not been able to
celebrate birthdays not being able to
meet on the anniversary of the debt of
passing away of a grandparent the times
when you would come together as a family
to support each other uh weren't there
and in a way we were the lucky ones we
didn't have an elderly person in a care
home but if we did imagine the rents
that you would feel today watching that
performance in Parliament when
potentially somebody that you love that
you cared for that raised you uh in a
care home you weren't able to see in the
final moments because you made the
sacrifice because you were asked to for
the national interest and Boris Johnson
didn't do that I just think he's told
deaf to wear the public are on this do
you think that some people might be
looking at this and thinking look it's
time to move on now and you know Boris
Johnson has been fined by police we've
been all through all this before peoples
have made up their minds on this already
why are we just going over the same
ground well I think integrity and
politics really matters I don't buy the
argument at all that all politicians are
the same that we're all in it for
ourselves the poor behavior in the way
that we're seeing and selfish behavior
is normal and should be accepted I think
the bar should be high and the public
have a right to for it to be high I
think the danger in what we see in
Parliament is being kind of dragged into
the gutter allows him to say but
everyone was doing it everyone was
breaking the rules you know I know that
everyone was at it everyone was not at
it I know people who work in the NHS and
all people that work in Care Homes I
know people that work for local councils
I know people right across the industry
in retail and other places who's stuck
to the rules because they were asked to
and they realized that there was a lot
of stake here like people would die in
the pandemic was ripping through society
and people that we cared about were
being lost that was the the context we
can't view what's going on today through
today's context where we're living our
lives in a in a freeway in terms of
should we just move on uh which is a you
know a question that I've seen being
asked I think accountability matters and
an inquiry by its nature is backward
looking that's what inquiry does and for
a political accountability it's
important that the prime minister of the
day who has so much of the nation is
held to account for the rules that he
set okay well we're here we heard from
Boris Johnson today we'll hear more I'm
sure as that goes on he says of course
that he did follow the rules and he
didn't willfully or intentionally
mislead Parliament um Keen to ask about
Richard cnx tax Affairs as well because
he has published those today it shows
what I guess we knew already that he's a
wealthy individual does that matter it
doesn't matter there's welfare uh in
fact I you know fair play for somebody
who's done well uh and who earns that
kind of money it doesn't mean he isn't
experiencing the cost of living crisis
in the way that many of us are and I
think a bit more understanding uh from
the Prime Minister and the chancellor
about the everyday struggles that people
are facing I think would go a long way
to rebuilding uh trust and faith and
democracy I think most MPS are
relatively wealthy if you look at and
look I know they're different levels but
if you look at the rest of the country
well I mean I left school at 15 I've
worked in many of the jobs that my
constituents work in and I know what
it's like to struggle and not be able to
pay bills and make the choices about who
in the family I know what it's like to
struggle and that by the way was in very
different circumstances we have family
tax credits that helped us I see people
today that are really struggling to make
ends meet and a government that isn't
providing the support that's needed you
know Labor's made calls for for instance
the non-dom tax status to be changed
we've made calls for the one percent uh
pension uh break that's currently being
put through that's costing a billion
pound not to be prioritized in favor of
support for working people and the Prime
Minister hasn't done that so it's not
about his personal wealth we knew that
he was well off it was about but does he
understand the real life lived
experience of working people in Britain
and I think the evidence says from the
budget that he just doesn't what about
capital gains tax talking about tax
policy because what these tax Affairs do
also show is that the amounts of tax
that you pay through Capital contains
taxes of course at substantially lower
rate to income tax is that fair well I
think we are going to have to review of
how tax uh in the UK is balanced whether
it's right and fair and proportionate
and whether it's equity for people
regardless of their work status uh
Rachel Reeves of course will be bringing
forward those plans as we get close to
the election there'll be more to say on
that but what we said for this budget is
that we can do far more on non-dom tax
status we can do far more on the one
percent who'll benefit from the pension
break to help working people today okay
thank you very much indeed it's great to
have you on the show today thank you
that's Jim McMahon a giving at Labor's
take well let's have a little bit of a
post-match uh Roundup Channel with our
deaf typical editor uh Sam Kate Sam
we're just talking there about Rishi cnx
tax Affairs
um
quick hand said that it was a complete
coincidence that that was published
today do we believe them
no of course we don't believe him what a
load of poppy
um
it's out of the way it was a great day
to do it it's um slightly embarrassing
just to be have a reminder that Rishi
sulac is as wealthy as he is now he is
married to the heires of a billionaire
but what today's tax return shows here
is that actually in his own right he's
incredibly wealthy the income in the
last three years uh just from salary and
interesting dividends of some
Investments comes over a million and
then there's another four million from
the increase in some investments in the
U.S so that makes him a very wealthy man
uh indeed you've got uh also quite a lot
of the money in an American Savings
Account uh that suggests that amount of
interest that he collects suggests that
he has about 80 000 pounds in that bank
account as well so lots of money a lot
of it tied up in the U.S rather than the
UK of course he used to live there uh
but I think it's striking that the man
who was Chancellor now prime minister
has his Investments there uh and um and
because as you were asking Jim McMahon
uh he has a lot of it tied up in
Investments that results in capital
gains rather than income and the attacks
at the lower level
just wanted to kind of like zoom out for
a minute because it's been a completely
breathtaking day should be saying
Westminster we had these three huge
stories going off we've had the tax
return that we're just talking about
there we've had Boris Johnson's evidence
we've had the brexit vote but on a
normal day would be leaving the news
agenda the vote on the Storm would break
on the Windsor framework if you like
it's a big day for this man the Prime
Minister how do you think he has emerged
after such a big day well I think he
probably will be quite happy tonight
today's been about burying things uh
burying tax returns in the greatest
political sense there's been a little
bit of burying Boris Johnson he may or
may not survive his whole privileges
committee but three and a half hours
questioning about his what he didn't do
wrong when he was in number 10 he's
never a good look and then the biggest
thing for him is that his biggest gamble
since becoming prime minister was to
renegotiate the brexit deal of the
Northern Ireland but the brexit deal and
he's got it through and he's not just
got it through he's smashed out of the
park in many ways in terms of his own
party and I'll be honest I remember
talking you know before the vote
thinking why is he doing this why is he
having this war this is only going to
end one way look at what happens through
his mail what happened to other people
before him and yeah actually I've I
guess I've improved wrong I'll admit him
I think Richie simack is the first Prime
Minister since John Major
to challenge to kind of write the
eurosceptic brexiteer now right of his
party and win everybody from David
Cameron onwards lost they tried it and
they lost and ultimately he's been the
first one in you know 30 years to be
able to do something that is no doubt
contentious there's no doubt that lots
of people would say the winter framework
which are just how Northern Ireland sits
within brexit sits within the union sits
within the European Union that has got
its own problems still but he's managed
to pull off a political trick and that's
put an end I really think to The brexit
Saga that's been going on since 2016.
today we closed a chapter of an enormous
book in our history it's massive massive
moments not what we've been talking
about but brexit is properly done today
and that's quite something yeah it is I
mean we're talking there about how
Richard synax emerged what about Boris
Johnson
so I just think that you know watching
him sit there and go I just don't
understand what the police were thinking
when they issued all those fines I don't
know why those people who advise me
would say all these things I don't know
why the rules were like that I I think
there's just a sense that although he
may be able to perform the role of
Greece Piglet and wiggle out of this
particular set of charges I think it's a
difficult day a reminder of the
difficult bits of Boris Johnson's Legacy
I suppose the brexit deal which sourced
out the problems his brexit deal created
I think it's been a day a bit of burying
this man uh well there you go thanks as
always for your analysis at Sam Coates
uh there that's it for the take we'll be
back next week and every week on
Wednesday at 9 00 PM next up Sky News at
10.
foreign
[Music]